[Applause]
oh my god people just screaming michael
joseph lived in this affordable housing
block for six years it took him 35
minutes to escape the fire as the smoke
was so thick i've never seen nothing
like this i don't know what causes that
fire to have broken out like this but
it's really tragic
nine children died in the fire and many
families have lost everything the new
york mayor is preparing to support a
community in grief many of these young
children went to schools
we will have a social and emotional
support at their schools
to help help the classmates
uh we're here as well with the red cross
and oem
is going to coordinate together to get
housing
and also some of the emergency needs
most of the people who lived in the
tower block were muslim and some of them
had moved here from gambia
they're being urged not to fear asking
for help even if they don't have the
correct immigration status know that if
you need assistance
you your names will not be turned over
to ice or any other institution
we want people to be comfortable and
coming forward i don't know he got a
baby in his hands a compensation fund is
being prepared for those affected by the
fire but their scars may take longer to
heal
barbara anger al jazeera